في السودان اعوام مره مرت بعد فرح لم يدم
طويلا بسقوط نظام احكم قبضته على البلاد
30 عاما استرعان ما دخلت البلاد نفقا
سياسيا ومؤسستيا مظلما لم تخرج منه بعد
صراع تلو اخر بين المدنيين والعسكريين حول
السلطه عمق الازمه وزاد من حده التممل
والاستياء لدى المواطنين الذين علقوا
املهم على عهد جديد تميزه الديمقراطيه
مظاهرات شعبيه كبيره تمكن من خلالها
السودانيون من ازاحه عمر البشير الذي ترك
تركه ثقيله على البلاد التي انتشر فيها
الفساد والنزاعات المسلحه الداخليه ابرزها
دارفور فعقب لطاحه به اجتماعات طويله
خاضتها قوى الحريه والتغيير مع المكون
العسكري في البلاد لرسم خريطه تضمن العوده
الى الشرعيه السياسيه عبر انتخابات
النزيهه غير ان حلم السودانيين لم يتحقق
تطورات متسارعه جاء اتباعا وتحديدا في
اغسطس 2019 مجلس السياده السوداني عين عبد
الله حمدوك رئيسا للوزراء لكنه لم يبقى
طويلا على راس الحكومه حيث انقلب عليه
الجيش في حمله اعتقالات طالته بالاضافه
الى عدد من وزراء حكومته بتاريخ الخامس
والعشرين من اكتوبر عام 2021
ردت عليه الولايات المتحده بتعليق مساعدات
بقيمه 700 مليون دولار للسودان الشارع رد
ايضا بمظاهرات ضد المكون العسكري في
الخرطوم واغلقت الشوارع دعما للقوى
السياسيه والاحتواء الغضب الشعبي افرجت
القياده العسكريه وتحديدا في الرابع من
نوفمبر من نفس العام عن اربعه وزراء كانوا
في حكومه عبد الله حمدوك واقام البرهان
بتشكيل مجلس سياده الانت جديد استبعد منه
اربعه ممثلين لقوى الحريه والتغيير هذه
الفوضى ادت الى ترد الوضع الانساني
والغذائي في السودان فاعلن البنك الدولي
ملحمه مليون دولار للخرطوم مقابل تحويلات
ماليه وغذائيه في يوليو عام 2022 في
الخامس من ديسمبر عام 2022
وسطت الاليه الثلاثيه نجحت باعاده الاطراف
المتصارعه الى طاوله المفاوضات مجددا
فاسهمت في توقيع الاتفاق للطاريه المبدئي
بين العسكريين والقوى السياسيه في الاشهر
القليله الماضيه وقبل ايام من التوقيع على
الاتفاق النهائي الذي يضم الجيش والدعم
السريع والقوى السياسيه انفجرت شراره
الحرب بين المكونين العسكريين في الخامس
عشر من هذا الشهر لتعيد البلاد الى المربع
الاول من الازمه
متابعه المزيد
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات